[Music]
the cloudiest dumbest series of league
of legends ever played wasn't some
random soloqueue game it was in the LPL
between IG and LGD two of the best teams
in the region with the spring 2015
playoffs on the horizon and the
invincible EDG awaiting the victor
both teams wanted nothing more than to
lose I like it don't mention the bud
Oh temp it fate to come through just to
make sure kid
is gonna be locked in position for
awhile that is not a good idea as got
these now just able to destroy him the
problem is that Ryan doesn't exactly
love it when teams sand bad and is
always ready to hand out penalty so the
team's have to get creative
ah the disrespect but pickup coming
through very no no no this is the pick
away Eve bud is what we have Atlas
living it to this game with my goodness
but that didn't change the fact that in
the weeks preceding the match everyone
from the community to the casters to the
competitors knew they were in for the
show of a lifetime though is oh my
goodness kid's gonna get grabbed on his
way back in here if with a massive flip
into the bottom line that's the tempered
fate kid still going to die almost
donates that kill over to God be there
in the mid lane it was set to be a big
ticket event a high-level match between
two pro teams who weren't trying to win
but the throw is the most inconspicuous
way possible the community called an
Oscar night we call it the biggest clown
fiesta and league of legends in history
in order to understand why IG and LGD
would risk being penalized just to avoid
playing in the same bracket as EDG
you've got to understand how good EDG
actually work doesn't find the gnar slam
he's trying to cut around SML Z is dead
oh my gosh is ridiculous Dante's got no
mana on with the full mark I turn around
lubbers caught Donna you are running but
pod destroys him with a double kill
loopers going to die as well this is
going to be an ace for Edward gaming and
they just beat masters 350 two and a
half minutes in that is the greatest
Lulu play I have ever seen pawn oh my
god hailed as a Chinese super power with
two Korean allege ins in pawn and death
EDG went on to bring down a truly
indomitable SKT at MSI 2015 here's the
last engage EDG doesn't even see the
turrets eyes on SKT stay Telecom t1 are
wiped the Nexus turrets are going down
LPL's Edward gaming for the 2015
midseason Invitational champions but
just a few weeks before MSI IG and LGD
were put in a position where if one of
them beat the other they'd have to play
EDG in the playoff bracket it also meant
that whoever lost wouldn't have to play
ATG until the grand final it wasn't long
before people started hyping up what an
absolute [ __ ] show it was gonna be the
community wanted to see just how daring
and shameless these players could be
they didn't know what they could and
couldn't get away with and well they
wanted to find out at first things
looked relatively standard despite some
sloppy team fighting they continued the
fight and flame gets taken down hop out
the shockwave under both of these Thank
You members becomes me he's gonna be
okay the equaliser comes down as well so
much a OE damage here from the IG lineup
as Godby not gonna be able to get too
much on kenny sir there's the command
protect I don't know whether it'll be
enough as the ignite takes down and got
B picks up the outside kill tbq still
here's the Dragons it's not in the
double kill now by the end of Game one
though things started to get a little
cloudy so I go to the bottom white key
careful as cbq just gonna try
clear out this creep late because this
sejuani is impossible to remove does get
the dragon rage back up again but in the
meantime the inhibitor turret is falling
down hahaha
some cheeky behavior here from zvq and
they're just proxy farming against each
other there yeah tbq or dodges out of
the way of the Arctic assault all comes
back up 20% slow as the telepods comes
in from zentai wanting to finish of what
was a gallant 1v1 and snags it would be
equalizer so in the end they use every
biggest Kakao is laughing his head off
kick out you were winning an honorable
jewel unfortunately for Eiji though they
went a little bit to try hard and
despite their best efforts they took a
one-game lead
needless to say LGD were truly
heartbroken at their loss just look at
God v look at how heartbroken he is
especially when he checks if that
cameraman is still watching him yeah it
certainly was gonna be there a little
bit upset saying why did I buy at
Luden's EKKO it's so pretty and I did so
much damage but I couldn't go golden
jokes aside he won was pretty tame and
fans were starting to worry that they
wouldn't get the [ __ ] they'd been
promised and then game 2 happened Johnny
into playoffs and two champion selected
your eyes are not following you that is
save in the mid lane instead of rookie
yeah
having unfortunately won the first game
i jus decided to substitute their
starting mid laner rookie for save a top
laner
in doing so they forfeited all three of
their bans setting the stage for some
truly hysterical picks but the save is
hovering and evelyn I wonder which patch
save thinks he's on because of course
save hasn't played for a while mind may
wander just play competitive for a while
I'm sure he's played League of Legends
quite recently it's not about that the
disrespect bog pickup coming through
very no no no this is the pick away Eve
bud is what we have Atlas moving it to
this game my goodness from this point on
the match slowly devolved into pure
you may have it was clear that both
teams were trying their hardest to lose
and while some performances were
oscar-worthy I like it you don't mention
the body Oh
temp it fate to come through just to
make sure kid is gonna be locked in
position for a while that is not a good
idea as god B's now just able to destroy
him kiddies is a [ __ ] had some very
choice words very supportive save he's
gonna be the beneficiary others were
more suited for a Razzie if with a
massive flip into the bottom line that's
a tepid fake kid still going to dump
rest turn it around now is a bet you can
count oh he lives the boiling no no he
doesn't he decides to walk back around
again and I have no idea what's going on
this game 25 minutes in IG and LGD were
neck-and-neck they'd taken no Drake no
towers past the second tier and racked
up nearly 50 kills it had got to the
point where players were visibly upset
over not dying by 37 minutes and the
kill count had just broken 80 and it was
clear that neither team was willing to
end the game we say a cone still farming
up in the bottom line even though he has
a six autumn built so that's a little
bit unnecessary 9 is just greedy 9/8 to
save up for his boots change the refs
actually called for a pause at which
point they probably pulled the players
to stop [ __ ] around absolutely no
idea pause is gonna come through though
we'll see exactly what happens off this
game but so far this one has been a very
interesting one
whatever happened during that pause it
worked within fifty seconds a major
objective had been taken this baron is
going to be taken down there very
quickly safe looking to try and get in
here but of course they have no vision
kiddies gets awarded but a little bit
too late a team secured an actual team
fight had broken out journey gonna be
taken by Akon to get him a free ride
into the backline shatters into the back
and this the tempered fake gonna walk
down these members are safe he's gonna
destroy him here as well LGG just
getting eradicated that is a buy for
nothing for IG and I don't know how they
do it and after blowing a baron buff LGD
off the rift IG sailed down the middle
lane to secure the most disappointing
victory of their lives my goodness it
was beautiful to say in IG they're gonna
walk down the 2
zero after this very interesting second
match prep final day of the LP oh yeah
it certainly was a cracker Atlas we saw
86 kills in 40 minutes it's worth
mentioning that despite the fact that
this happens a lot in traditional sports
this is the first time a major region in
league of legends has produced such
blatant sandbagging hilariously ing did
actually go on to get viciously three
owed by EDG in the semi finals and
Latini on the other hand made it all the
way to the grand finals and welcome on
to the rift as we jump in for the level
1 of our first game have a best-of-five
between Edward gaming and LG where you
know they lost GDG Oscar night stands
alone as the worst series in a league of
Legends history or that's probably how
riot feels about it
as far as were concerned it was pretty
great thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]